bonsoir
j'espère que tout le monde se porte bien
et que sa vue puis arrivé ici sans des
embouteillages mais je sais que c'est
pas le cas dans le doublage
merci beaucoup merci beaucoup a dit
matthew et c'est avec fierté que
celui-là ce soit avec vous pour partager
un peu le même parcours et déjà je vous
dis je ne suis pas tellement francophone
je me débrouille un peu donc si je me
cale un peu soyez sûr que je vais
commencer à parler en anglais donc c'est
un peu ça je suis sékou kaba 100% en
guinée mais ici j'ai quitté la guinée en
2001 avec la famille et nous avons
commencé
on peut dire faire une autre vie de
nouveau en amérique qu au michigan
et là je suis arrivé il fallait pas du
tout l'anglais a fait c'était de
français que j'ai commencé avec vu que
je suis d ici donc j'ai commencé et dès
le début vraiment j'ai su que je ne suis
pas je ne suis pas comme les autres je
suis que je suis un peu différent et que
je suis un peu plus curieux que les
autres j'ai un peu plus de d'énergie que
les autres et vraiment
je refuse j'ai refusé en fait d'accepter
non comme qu'on repense pas ce que je
peux dire que ma tête un peu bizarre la
chose qu'on me dit que je ne peux pas je
ne peux pas faire c'est effectivement un
sac je veux faire et dès l'enfance
vraiment j'étais un petit est au bilan
la famille peut dire et en fait c'était
parce que j'aime l aventure j'aimais
trop d'aventuré tout ce qu'on me disait
de ne pas faire effectivement c'est ça
je faisais donc
arriver au michigan je sus que vraiment
à la vie à l'est dur parce que
effectivement je parlais pas français
c'était un peu différent que les uns et
les autres américains et moi je suis
africaine donc via le début son goût ont
commencé à se moquer de moi je ne me
sentais pas trop bien où je ne me
sentais pas comme j'ai fait partie d'une
communauté en fait et dès le début je me
suis renfermée et je faisais ce que je
voulais sauf ce que je voulais et je
n'allais pas écouter quelqu'un qui
allait s'arrêter devant moi en fait
comme obstacles et il faut à l'école je
suis après le code je suis sorti une
fois me baladant j'ai rencontré une
piste en fait et en engrais ses tracks
et une fois arrivé à côté j'ai vu un
grand n'était plus âgés que moi donc dès
que je m'arrête sur la piste je voyais
tout quelque chose de grand grande
taille et
il atterrit de l'autre côté continuer à
courir je dis oh mon dieu mon père va
créer sur moi parce qu'il me dit tout le
temps de rester calmes et moi vraiment
c'est ça qui me prend la tête et c'est
ça que moi je vais faire dès le début ça
c'était en 2001 et le lendemain
effectivement je me suis retrouvé à
l'entraînement et c'est que
le gars a sauté en français c'est un 1er
je pense que c'est ça être ado enso et
est c est assez talent ça commence
peut-être à 30 cm que dire donc c'est
pas trop et petit à petit petit à petit
j'ai aussi amélioré dans le sport et au
fur et à mesure tu t'améliores au fur et
à mesure
les montes de taille et finalement à la
fin sa vie à 107 mètres donc un peu
comme ça pour les adultes et pendant mon
parcours j'ai su très tôt que il faut
que je me sacrifie et il faut que je
fais beaucoup de sacrifices pour
vraiment y arriver où
je n'y pensais pas même moi des fois
mais vraiment pour me donner au fonds
pour me donner au fond parce que je
pense que l'être humain le corps humain
c'est une machine et c'est à nous de
vraiment
essayer de voir ce qu'on peut faire avec
notre propre machine ça commence par
l'esprit la tête je pense que c'est là
que tout se passe donc il faut se former
se donner au fonds mentalement
complètement et des fois d'une manière
que toi même tu te crois
fou on peut dire
et quand je dis flou c'est vraiment
croire en un premier mantois même
deuxièmement
une seule chose que tu prends pour toi
que tu as comme objectif que peut-être
personne ou à côté de toi
dans connaît rien et
la seule chose a pu vraiment changé
d'avis
la seule chose à peut vraiment changer
ta vie et pour moi c'était l'obstacle
l'obstacle qui était devant moi qui
étais les ai donc 2001 à
chaque jour chaque jour que je me suis
rêver c'était la première chose auquel
je pensais chaque jour est vu lait est
je vous parle de la seule chose qui peut
changer notre vie quand je me lavais
quand je mangeais je me réveillais à la
seule chose que je pensais je n'avais
pas beaucoup d'amis donc c'est bien
sacrifier sa les sorties je n'avais pas
le temps parce que ça n'avait rien à
voir avec mon objectif et mon objectif
c'était de voir ce que je peux faire
avec ma machine qui est mon corps et mon
esprit en fait j'étais complètement
focus je sais même pas comment mais bon
peut-être
l'obstacle que j'aime trop on peut dire
au volcan ne savent pas qu'on dise en
français
donc tous les jours tous les jours je me
réveille je fais quelque chose
petits ou grands qui peuvent emmener un
peu loin un peu un peu proche à peu près
je pense de mon objectif est petit à
petit quand on prend une chose on se
donne au fond on a le focus est vraiment
par la grâce de dieu on avance un peu et
dans tout ça le sacrifice est vraiment
important parce que oui en tant que
jeune tu toi tes propres qui était
propre idée de comment les journées se
passent
mais en sacrifiant en allant vers tes
objectifs
la vie est complètement différente en
fait complètement pour vous donner une
idée dès l'âge de
12 ans on peut dire
pendant les 24 heures je me réveille à 6
heures pour aller à l'entraînement de
basket après l'enterrement de basket à 8
heures l'école commence à 8h30 de 8h30 à
15h10 les codes fini de 15h30 je prends
le bus pour aller où je m'entraîne pour
l'athlétisme qui est une heure donc
disons 16h30 et je m'entraîne de 16h30 à
10 ans
21h30 22h30 donc encore une heure pour
arriver à la maison
22h30 23h
manger prier dit ado un moment peut pas
dormir et refaire
donc j'ai fait ça pendant des années
sans même y penser parce que vraiment
c'était ce que je voulais faire j'ai
métro j'aimais trop et je me suis donné
au fond complètement le petit à petit
petit à petit avec les sacrifices
et
le support le support de mon équipe une
équipe qui était mon entraîneur et mes
coéquipiers les choses ont avancé un peu
se sont avancés un peu et 2007 les
parents ont décidé de déménager au
canada
je suis arrivé et une fois là bas encore
je connais personne je connais pas la
ville je connais rien tout ce que je
sais qu'il fait froid c'est tout donc je
me suis encore renfermé et je dis je
vais continuer sur ce chemin et tout ce
qui est bruit ou tout ce qui est comme
distraction
je ne ne veut même pas entendre une fois
encore je me suis donné au fond au fond
au fond et petit à petit on me dit je
commence à entendre que ah oui toi tu
n'es pas mal tu sais ya des opportunités
que tu peux gagner en faisant ça je dis
ah oui comme quoi à peut-être si tu
continues tu peux tout faire sans même
payer un franc je dis ah oui ok y'a pas
de problème donc ça me motive et jeu je
me donne encore au fond un peu et
effectivement ce qui s'est passé je n'ai
rien payé dès que j'ai vraiment pour moi
c'est apprendre des sports au sérieux je
n'ai rien payé et finalement à la fin
ils m'ont ils ont commencé à me payer
moi donc la vie bizarre comme ça tu
prends une chose tu te donnes au pharo
au fond est vraiment ça peut ouvrir une
grande porte ou des portes en même temps
et par la grâce de dieu j'ai eu
l'opportunité
et d'aller représenter le canada aux
jeux olympiques en 2016
qui était
une
je n'arrive même pas à expliquer des
fois parce que dis tu si tu prends le
petit de conakry en 2001 lady qui va les
représenter un pays de l'extérieur
au niveau des jeux olympiques j'aurais
dit que tu es complètement fou un peu
aussi mais effectivement c'est ce qui
s'est passé et une fois là bas j'ai
vraiment j'ai vu que dans cette vie
non seulement la vie est saine mais des
fois c'est nous mêmes qui complique les
choses pour nous et à la base choisie
une chose dont toi au fond
donnons-nous au fond de tous nos petits
activités et à la fin le choisissons
à la fin trois y sont un ou deux
pouvoirs plein débit mais quand même
vraiment après ça le monde s'est
complètement ouverte pour moi et là où
je suis je pense j'ai fait
35 pays pour les voyages je n'ai rien
payé sa saveur avec le sport soit pour
les conférences où la compétition ou
juste parce que j'ai parlé avec un gars
pendant le networking et me dit ah oui
j'étais l'entreprise ici vient juste
pour thil et je paye pour tout et puis
tu te retournes jeudi y'a pas de
problème allons-y et ça se trouve que
c'est un homme
quelqu'un d'un autre comment 10h aux
cadres dans un pays différent et cette
fois tout le temps je m'assois judy
attend juste parce que moi j'ai décidé
de sauter sur un petit truc de mettre
cette ombre offre des opportunités de
ouf deux fois mais bon ça a été ma seule
chose à quoi je voulais me donner 100%
est vraiment vraiment ça m'a donné
beaucoup d'opportunités et à 2019
j'ai pris leur retraite à 29 ans et on
se moque de moi deux fois dix dates et
toujours jeune tu veux continuer j'ai
dit non j'ai fait pour plus de 15 ans
j'ai complètement fatigué et dans le
sport vraiment j'ai eu plus que je
voulais donc dieu merci pour ça et
encore comme ça finit jamais cette vie
sauf quand on
je me suis dit bon tempo nous arrange et
7 challans était de retourner au pays et
j'ai quitté quand j'avais neuf ans donc
on peut dire que je ne savais rien
pendant ces prenant les vingt ans que
j'ai fait surtout la guinée deux fois
deux semaines deux semaines donc j'ai
fait l'équivalent d'un mois en guinée
pendant 20 ans donc je ne connaissais
rien du tout même le petit français que
je dis là c'est pendant mes deux ans a
ici que je les ai tout appris parce que
c'était tout andré en fait tout c'était
un gros et ça a vraiment été dur au
début ça a vraiment été dur au début
mais je me suis dit je suis là pour moi
même ce tarif richard winsor ce quelque
chose de nouveau à quoi j'ai pu me
donner aux à fond encore est ce vraiment
pour
reconnaître le pays parce que quand les
choses sauf dans la vie il faut toujours
se retourner à la source et c'est pour
ça je suis là et quelques tas après
maintenant je commence à connaître un
peu le pays je connais quelques
peu dire que secrets du pays je connais
des gens qui arriverait d'évoquer les
choses au moins et
à la base ce pays à durrës
pays est dure mais
la vie aussi dur donc on fait comment
nous sommes là on se cherche et cherche
à se voiler pour nous tous un chalet à
s'évader pour nous tous est actuellement
géré une entreprise de
[Musique]
transformation d'huile de palme rouge et
d'autres usines se trouvent à tombolia
je vous invite tous de venir c'est
vraiment une belle chose qu'on a monté
très vite pendant trois mois et là nous
notre capacité nous pouvons faire plus
de cinq à sept mille bouteilles chaque
jour dépendant de notre effort donc la
bouteille mise en bouteille même notre
propre votre propre bouteille nous
souffrons l'autisme et ville s'appelle
nîmes bat rennes prend brouillaud et
donc petit à petit la guinée commença
à servir pour moi comme
a parfois on peut dire pour vraiment
créer quelque chose de nouveau contribué
au pays et
continuer à me sacrifier vous que
vraiment la seule chose que je décide à
faire de ma vie ça continue comme je lé
fais sur la piste d'athlétisme donc
vraiment merci beaucoup
enjoy the west
[Applaudissements]